el sonido de las sirenas de defensa
civil derivan una evacuación masiva de
los ciudadanos de la región separatista
de doñes al este de Ucrania las
autoridades de la autoproclamada
república denuncian que kiev planea
lanzar una ofensiva contra las áreas por
rusas las mujeres los niños y los
ancianos eran evacuados primero según el
acuerdo con los dirigentes de la
federación rusa en la región de rostov
se prepararon lugares para recibir y
alojar a nuestro ciudadanos a los
evacuados se les proporcionará todo lo
necesario para cruzar rápidamente la
frontera se han establecido todas las
condiciones en los puestos de control
explosión
el líder Pro ruso de lugán también está
a los residentes a salir hacia la
federación rusa lo antes posible por su
parte desde kiefacusana Moscú de Lanzar
provocaciones con el fin de incitar a
los militares ucranianos a responder
esas áreas para recuperar nuestros
territorios puedo decir que estas
declaraciones no tienen nada que ver con
la realidad
coinciden con las advertencias de
Estados Unidos sobre los llamados
atentados de falsa bandera que según un
accidente el kremlin utilizaría para
justificar la temida invasión a